[Musica]
grazie
ciao a tutti
vorrei cominciare con una premessa
questa è la prima volta che mi trovo a
parlare in pubblico e ho sempre avuto
molta paura
questo perché durante la mia adolescenza
infanzia sono sempre stata una persona
timida e introversa e questo può portare
ovviamente la maggior parte delle
persone a pensare che una cosa negativa
quando in realtà per me ad oggi è una
risorsa vera e propria essere da soli
permette di esplorare realtà parallele o
creare mondi immaginari sicuramente però
rende ancora più difficile parlare a voi
oggi
per fortuna però nella mia vita ho
trovato un modo per comunicare questi
mondi queste storie e lo faccio
attraverso la mia arte per cui oggi sono
qui e vorrei condividere parte del mio
percorso con voi
e
quindi mi presento mi chiamo giusta
moroso e sonar director and digital
artist e se l'artista mi ha permesso di
potermi esprimere liberamente a livello
creativo ma soprattutto di poter vivere
la mia più grande passione
sicuramente ad oggi c'è tantissima
tantissima ammirazione per gli artisti
digitali e sicuramente questo anche
grazie a internet e social media per cui
se punto prima erano meno conosciuti
oggi e digital artist possono inserirsi
molteplici contesti
e quindi oggi sono qui per portarvi con
meno un percorso per raggiungere la
libertà creativa ed espressiva
come la maggior parte delle migliori
cose che accadono secondo me tutto ha
inizio con un errore ormai più di dieci
anni fa quando ho studiato sociologia
alla sapienza
ho avuto modo sicuramente di potermi
confrontare veri tematiche interessanti
che ancora oggi fanno parte del mio
bagaglio culturale ma sicuramente mi
hanno fatto capire il mio bisogno di
dovermi esprimere che un mezzo che non
fosse quello verbale o scritto
convincere poi i miei genitori è stato
ovviamente il passo successivo e quindi
l'accademia il master le riproduzioni
virtuali mi hanno aperto un nuovo mondo
a nuove realtà da scoprire è quello che
più mi affascinava non era appunto il
fatto che con queste tecnologie potessi
riprodurre ciò che è noto quindi ciò che
fa parte della nostra vita quotidiana ma
che con questo tipo di tecnologie
possiamo e potevo plasmare qualsiasi
cosa io volessi immaginarsi
come è giusto che sia la mia persona nel
linguaggio visivo il mio lavoro cambiano
e si sviluppano col passare del tempo ma
c'è una cosa che secondo me rimane
immutabile della contemplazione della
natura
la natura e la mia più grande fonte di
ispirazione
vedo la natura come una programmazione
perfetta quando cerco di guardare il
mondo dal punto di vista strutturale e
formale
ed è fatto una rivoluzione appunto
continua di frattali che questi sono tra
di loro in una maniera incredibile
infatti uno degli aspetti visivi che
esplora maggiormente è quello
dell'alterazione dell'espressione
naturale quindi vado sempre alla ricerca
di forme alternative o ibride che spesso
si concretizzano in
espressioni biomeccaniche liene dello
scenario naturalistico
sicuramente però questo mi andare oltre
quindi cercare queste forme alternative
nasce in parallelo al percorso che ho
fatto con l'esperienza e psichedeliche e
sono stati dei momenti di fondamentale
importanza per il mio sviluppo creativo
anche personale in quanto mi hanno fatto
capire che la realtà che ci circonda può
cambiare anche drasticamente rispetto al
senso comune
sono stati fondamentali durante questo
percorso due autori che voglio citare
oggi e sono terence mckenna e stanislav
grof ed è proprio grazie a loro scritti
che ho capito che effettivamente la
realtà
cosciente ci mette in contatto con una
piccolissima soltanto con una
piccolissima frazione di ciò che stiamo
quindi significa che con questo tipo di
esperienze riusciamo a trascendere
quelli che sono i limiti del nostro eco
ea rivendicare un'identità completa ma
cosa significa
significa che con questo tipo di
esperienze riusciamo a identificarci con
il creato o addirittura il principio
creativo stesso
e sono sicuramente delle esperienze
profonde esperienze importanti che sento
di
consigliarvi ma che ovviamente devono
essere fatte con una certa
consapevolezza per poter ovviamente
comprendere al meglio
e quindi dal design sono partita da
sociologia poi ho studiato design del
prodotto e quindi anche le riproduzioni
architettoniche sono poi finalmente
approdata al mondo digitale è la virtual
reality
sicuramente durante questo passaggio non
ho potuto non accorgermi che
effettivamente c'è tanto in comune tra
psichedelia e virtual reality
e voi vi chiedete ma com'è possibile che
c'è tanto in comune tra ciò che
spirituale e ciò che tecnologico
anche ovviamente mi sono fatta questa
domanda ho trovato nelle risposte fatto
che entrambe hanno la capacità di
alterare i limiti della realtà cosciente
entrambe possono alterare l'esperienza
sensoriale ed evocare percorsi interiori
trasformativi ed entrambe ci fanno
andare oltre quelli che sono appunto i
vincoli della nostra esperienza
coscienze
e quindi questo andare oltre nelle mie
opere uno degli aspetti fondamentali e
secondo me chiunque può andare oltre
quello che è comunemente immagina e
chiunque vuole inventare il conosciuto
per poi poter plasmare il nuovo
sicuramente secondo me questo si applica
non soltanto le discipline artistiche ma
in tutte le discipline in tutti i campi
in cui in realtà noi ci impegniamo
usiamo le nuove tecnologie per
raccontare nuove storie
creare nuovi mondi nuove realtà ma
soprattutto ci accorgiamo di quanto
valiamo e di quanto possiamo dare e
facciamo le nostre passioni dei grandi
punti di forza
nella mia vita
parlando l'aspetto lavorativo sono stata
fortunata ha avuto tantissime richieste
di lavoro
ho lavorato e collaborato con brand
clienti importanti e conosciuti e quando
mi sono trasferita nel 2019 a berlino
sono a contatto con tantissime persone
che mi hanno fatta anche crescere a
livello artistico
e personale
le quali una di queste sam che anche uno
dei miei più grandi amici con il quale
appunto insieme abbiamo fondato il
nostro studio ha johar fitti nel quale
ci occupiamo dsga e e via fax
sono stati appunto dei periodi interesse
un periodo veramente interessante della
mia vita dove ho potuto sperimentare
intrigante anche in un certo senso ma
sentivo che effettivamente c'era
qualcosa che mancava e verrà dato dal
fatto che non avevo più tempo da
dedicare a me stessa e alla mia alte
fondamentalmente
però nel 2020 c'è un cambiamento
importante perché venga introdotta il
mondo degli inerti
non so se ne avete sentito parla di
energie ma in sé stessa per non fan gb
il token cioè una risorsa digitale che
si può identificare unicamente sulla
block chain e che tra le altre si può
riferire ad un'opera d'arte digitale
vera e propria
è un aspetto interessante di questa
tecnologia e che può fornire una prova
di autenticità che ovviamente parte
fondamentale del mondo del collezionismo
quindi inerti e tecnologia blog chain
hanno sicuramente aperto un mondo ha
gli artisti digitali digital artist che
finalmente
per vari per vari per vari aspetti vari
vari
scusate
vari aspetti dal fatto che ovviamente
c'è stato tantissimo
si è parlato tanto di questo argomento
quindi stanno diventando comunque mentre
e anche per il fatto che finalmente si è
potuto provare che l'arte digitale
quindi quella creata attraverso le
supporti tecnologici non è assolutamente
meno importante rispetto a quella creata
attraverso i supporti fisici canonici
e quindi dal punto di vista lavorativo
sicuramente sono create delle rimane
dinamiche molto interessanti
date dal fatto che finalmente gli
artisti possono essere liberi da fattori
esterni quali flussi di lavoro o
richieste di clienti e per quanto mi
riguarda non doveva che
per che fare con contratti o richieste
di lavoro ha sicuramente è stato un
motivo di grande sollievo
e quindi attraverso che ne stia appunto
finalmente iris all'arti si possono dare
voce alle proprie idee
e la propria creatività è effettivamente
però voglio dire anche che
non tutte le volte con lavorato per il
cliente è stato comunque negativo ma
sono stati a volte delle collaborazioni
interessanti sono create delle sinergie
particolari per cui è stato anche bello
però effettivamente c'è da dire una cosa
che i soldi possono pagare le ore di
lavoro ma non la creatività all ispirata
assolutamente
voglio tornare tenerti e voglio
aggiungere una cosa che per quanto
possano essere un'idea formidabile dal
punto di vista teorico e pratico
sicuramente c'è un aspetto negativo dato
dal fatto che intorno a questa
tecnologia purtroppo si è creata una
sorta di speculazione selvaggia
e mi auguro vivamente che nel futuro
assistiamo un cambiamento che tenga
conto molto più gli aspetti etico
finanziari
e quindi adesso finalmente posso
definirmi un artista full time col tempo
da dedicare a me stessa e alla mia arte
col tempo da dedicare a cercare appunto
nuove forme di ispirazione che possono
essere trovate appunto in nuove forme di
vita in esseri umani in nuovi posti che
visito nuove culture ma soprattutto
forme di vita che in realtà possono
essere più vicini a noi di ciò che voi
immaginate
noi possiamo essere queste forme di vita
che cambiano la realtà il modo di vedere
la realtà nostra e quella degli altri
e quindi voglio concludere con una cosa
dicendo se nella vita può essere un
artista sia artista se incontrerà i
durante il tuo percorso delle persone
che vi dicono che non è un lavoro che
non ce la farai che non ne vale la pena
rischiare che ti critica occhi non ti
supporta fregatene vai avanti anzi
quello che devi fare è portare la tua
visione al mondo perché è la diversità
che ricchezza e della diversità che
intriga è sorta e stimola grazie
[Applauso]